[Musique]
de toute façon en toi on se voit ventes
ont dépassé la phase i non van driessche
pas
c'est vendredi c'est trop franchement
franchement j'ai juste entendu mal
allons bien j'aime comme des raisons
était pas parce qu'on est petit bout de
nice ce soir les épreuves d'agility d'al
bou bess jamais s'ils continuent même
tenu à paris des profs bailly chargée
comme ben voilà un classique
on y vient la bracine sescousse atteste
déjà avec d'autres l'appellent rue
balore vente mot bonhomme de même un
genre d'alain delon mélangé avec un
pitch sérieux mélanger la gamme maroc
moi j'ai toujours eu un faible pour les
basques le père demain un beau grand
portugais connaissent un hiver dans
l'épouvanté tout le monde
bon moi les gars jouent ce bail qu'il
voit jamais au balo le boudin jamais et
c'est vrai je suis brûlé mais
franchement je croyais que tous
voulaient parce que j'entends qu'il ya
des flèches maquette pour être des
chiffres bons films étudiants mais j'ai
dicté par l'agm attend est content qu'il
se sent plus mais j'ai ma semaine encore
j'ai brûlé ou en faisant un match on
voit backpack ce texte